Salut à vous tous, les membres de la team mentalo.
Alors, je fais la vidéo ce samedi soir, dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
Ce qui explique ces jolies cernes
Pour parler avec vous de 2017.
Donc ne ce sera pas une vidéo à proprement parler sur le mentalisme,
mais j'aimerais vraiment que vous regardiez la vidéo parce que je vais avoir besoin de vous,
pour prendre des décisions.
Et je veux pas faire genre "Donnez-moi votre avis" et en fait j'ai mon plan prédéfini et je m'en occupe,
ça va être très important pour moi et il est temps que je me mette aussi à travailler pour l'année prochaine.
♪ générique ♪
Toute l'année depuis le premier janvier, à chaque fois que j'avais une décision à prendre,
j'en parlais avec vous, et quand on était moins nombreux, j'avais pratiquement tout le monde qui me répondait.
Là maintenant c'est différent : on est beaucoup plus nombreux sur la chaîne,
Et de fait y en a déjà qui sont partis de cette vidéo parce que ça les intéresse moins la vie de la chaîne en elle-même.
Alors je compte sur vous dans les commentaires et au sondage que je mettrai à la fin,
pour me dire ce que vous ce que vous aimeriez, vous, et aussi pourquoi.
J'ai décidé de faire cette vidéo sous forme de conversation avec vous,
donc j'ai rien écrit de spécial, je vais pas m'amuser à jouer ou à essayer de vous faire des blagues,
j'vous parle vraiment comme à des potes, filles et garçons, qui seraient là devant moi, et avec qui je discuterais.
Il reste donc 76 vidéos avant la fin de l'année, donc je travaille le MentalVlog comme d'habitude,
quotidiennement, je suis déjà en train de travailler sur la vidéo du 31 décembre,
et si vous avez suivi vous savez qu'elle sera doublement spéciale,
31 décembre que je passerai sur scène, c'était pas prévu au départ, j'ai pas du tout pris conscience
que ce serait la fin de ce défi... Je sais pas, sinon j'aurais peut-être organisé quelque chose, quoique,
c'est le 31, personne n'aurait été dispo, enfin voilà, c'est comme ça et ce sera aussi bien d'être dans un truc
un peu festif.
J'commence à prendre conscience que ça va m'faire bizarre d'arrêter le rythme d'une vidéo par jour.
En 2017 donc je vais me lancer un nouveau défi, ça c'est sûr, c'est établi, je sais exactement lequel c'est!
J'vous l'annoncerai bien sûr à la fin de l'année.
Toujours en vidéo, c'est toujours en rapport avec le mentalisme, c'est toujours sur Youtube,
mais c'est autre chose.
J'pense aussi continuer à faire des vidéos régulières, un petit peu dans le format MentalVlog.
Pas tous les jours, ça n'aurait pas de sens, mais peut-être une, deux, trois fois par semaine,
j'me suis pas encore positionné là-dessus.
Et j'vais découvrir ce que c'est d'avoir du temps pour bosser plus ses vidéos, pouvoir faire des vidéos un petit peu plus longues
Améliorer les montages, vous donnez plus de sources, en fait approfondir simplement certains sujets
que j'aimerais approfondir avec vous
Et puis à côté de ça, y a quelque chose qui me trotte dans la tête depuis 2/3 semaines
C'est rapport aux vlogs
Bon, vous savez que je joue un spectacle depuis 4 ans et demi, que je suis en train d'écrire le nouveau qui commence en janvier,
Mais y a pas que ça en fait, qui se passe, y a d'autres projets, disons qui sont en train de naître
Soit dans la réalité soit juste dans mon esprit pour l'instant, avec certaines envies
Et tout ça, ça a un rapport avec le mentalisme à chaque fois
Mais ça n'a pas rapport direct à 100%  avec YouTube. Et quand j'ai monté le MentalVlog,
J'ai mis le mot "vlog" parce que je voulais
faire des vlogs, aussi, de toutes ces activités-là
et au final le  vlog, c'est ce
que je fais le moins sur la chaine
alors je me dis est-ce que ça vaudrait
pas le coup que pour 2017
ou même avant d'ailleurs,
je projetais 2017 mais ça pourrait être
avant
pourquoi je n'ouvrirai pas une chaine secondaire qui me permettrait de vloguer
c'est à dire en permanence avec ma
caméra et de vloguer ce qu'est la
construction du spectacle les dates de
tournée et les autres projets et aussi
à côté en cours vous savez que je voudrais
m'essayer à écrire un livre
je sais pas si ça sortira un jour mais je pourrais filmer aussi les choses que je fais pour écrire le livre
ou simplement vous
parler à vous, à la caméra ça serait
jamais du vlog de vie privée
directement mais une sorte de rendez-vous
alors il n'y aurait pas... dans  mon idéal,
il n'y aurait pas de jour fixe de sortie même pas de rythme en fait
peut-être que des fois il y en aurai beaucoup et des fois, il n'y en aurait pas durant moment
Ce serai vraiment lié à mes activités et si il y a quelque
chose à vloguer ou pas ou à discuter ou pas
Il n'y aura pas forcément de gros
montages derrière. Il n'y aurait pas forcément de grosses contraintes
enfin quand je dis gros montage
évidemment je mettrai que les
choses qui sont intéressantes mais je
chercherai pas à développer cette chaîne
en fait, pour tout vous dire,
j'aurais adoré vloguer
Ce qui était de faire ce défi là cette année
ça aurait été marrant,en fait, j'ai pas du tout pensé mais, d'avoir un espèce de making of de
en fait c'est quoi concrètement de
devoir faire des vidéos la nuit,
de les écrire de les monter avant de se coucher
d'être en carence de sommeil
tu vois tous ces trucs là ça aurait pu
être intéressant
de partager avec vous
mais je ne l'ai pas fait donc cette chaîne
secondaire pourrait aussi pallier à tout ça
j'aimerais avoir votre avis dessus:
Est-ce que vous trouvez que c'est une bonne
idée, pas une bonne idée est-ce que
vous pensez que non vaut mieux faire ce
genre de choses aussi sur la chaîne
mais pas trop fréquents est-ce qu'il
faut lancer ça en 2017 ou qu'en 2016 ou jamais
j'aimerais avoir votre avis
là-dessus
votre avis également sur le
fait de l'année prochaine continuer à
faire
un petit peu du contenu similaire
de mentalisme sur le mentalvlog
mais peut-être
une fois par semaine ou plusieurs fois
par semaine enfin voila j'aimerais avoir
vos avis sur tout ça et vous
inquiétez pas pour le défi je me donne
pour 2017 ça je vous le dirais plus tard
Je ne sais plus ce que j'était en train de
dire parce que je viens d'avoir un
problème avec ma carte sd
Ca fait une heure et demie
une heure trente que j'essaye de
réparer le problème avec toutes mes cartes sd...
Bref !
J'ai enfin réussi. Je vais pas
vous mentir c'est la journée la plus dure pour moi
de toute l'année pour faire la vidéo. D'où cet état de
fatigue qui fait que là je commence à
péter les plombs je vous ai posé pleins
de questions répondez-moi dans les
commentaires je vous mets un sondage
également pour savoir ce que vous
pensez de cette chaîne secondaire
Oui, non,  c'est une très
mauvaise idée Fabien, Ah c'est un coup
de génie c'est vous qui me dites c'est
vous qui voyez merci d'être là j'ai
hâte d'être demain
pour écrire une vidéo
plus dynamique dirons-nous allez
passer un bon dimanche rendez-vous
demain
en pleine forme à 17 heures
Ciao !